cryptage tout de suite avec bruno draft
historien spécialiste de l'europe de
l'est bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france expliqué nous pour quelles
raisons est ce que la cour
constitutionnelle polonaise tarde-t-elle
à rendre sa décision concernant la
primauté du droit européen sur la
législation polonaise bien sûr c'est
qu'ici c'est dû aux rapports de force
entre bruxelles et varsovie qui est
difficile et pas uniquement à cause de
cette question il ya beaucoup d'autres
dossiers qui complique les relations
entre bruxelles et varsovie et bien sûr
je pense que nous sommes dans une partie
de transfert de conversations et de
négociations qui ne sont pas dites tout
cela pour créer un rapport de force
parce qu'enfin ce qui qui a derrière
indépendamment évidemment des jugements
que l'on peut porter sur les autorités
de varsovie sur les politiques
intérieures du gouvernement pour le
neige et sur ses choix bien sûr ce qui
est en cours en en conflit c'est
fondamentalement larchitecture que devra
prendre l'union européenne est ce que
l'union européenne est une fédération
d'états ou est-ce que l'union européenne
est une confédération d'états souverains
c'est ce que met évidemment l'actuel
gouvernement polonais sur le terrain
mais c'est le cas aussi d'autres
gouvernements comme la hongrie qui
essaient de profiter de la crise
provoquée par le bric sic pour
refonder si je peux dire les structures
de l'union européenne alors pour rester
sur cette décision très attendue de la
cour constitutionnelle polonaise qu'est
ce qui est en jeu aussi en termes de
politiques antérieures
ce qui est en jeu bien sûr qu'il ya là
qu'il est question intérieure liée à
dison
l'administration de la justice en
pologne par un gouvernement qu on peut
évidemment critiquer ça ou là par
rapport aux principes fondateurs de ce
qu'est une démocratie
occidentale de type occidental donc là
évidemment cette question
ressurgit plus largement il y à aussi
la tentative de maintenir
son autorité morale auprès d'eux une
polonaise parce que la politique disons
de bras de fer de varsovie tout au moins
dans le sur le plan du langage permet à
beaucoup de polonais de se sentir un peu
plus fier auparavant un peu plus
affirmatif qu'auparavant et
bien sûr il s'agit donc de ce qu'on
appelle en occident le populisme terme
qui peut être contestée par ailleurs il
s'agit évidemment de flatter une opinion
qui n'est pas seulement comme ça a été
dit
intéressé par la question de la justice
et de la supériorité du droit polonais
ou du droit européen mais qui peut il
serait intéressé par des questions
beaucoup plus triviale comme le maintien
du secteur charbonnier en pologne contre
la politique de bruxelles à un moment où
on voit qu'il y à l'égard du charbon en
pologne en europe pardon une politique
de deux poids deux mesures entre les
grandes puissances européennes comme
l'allemagne et des pays de moins grande
importance quand les pays d'europe du
centre est alors on va revenir sur cette
question mais avant cela pour qu'on
comprenne bien très concrètement que
pourrait entraîner une décision de la
cour constitutionnelle polonaise une
décision favorable à la primauté de la
législation polonaise sur le droit
européen très concrètement ça ça
donnerait quoi au quotidien ça donne ça
donne quelque chose qui est dans l'état
actuel des institutions européennes
quelque chose qui est inacceptable pour
bruxelles toute la question est
évidemment de savoir si les polonais
iront jusqu'au bout de cette démarche
est la deuxième question est ce que
l'union européenne est prêt à revoir le
feu son fonctionnement en particulier
dans la question de la justice et comme
je vous le disais ça va beaucoup plus
loin c'est la question est ce que les
droits nationaux sont supérieurs au
droit européen ou le contraire c'est
évidemment une lutte de pouvoir qui est
absolument fondamental pour l'avenir de
l'union européenne mais ce qu'on peut
imaginer que l'union européenne invite
la pologne a quitté le ou que la pologne
décide de quitter les lieux je pense que
ce sera très difficile d'imaginer un pot
lexique pour l'union européenne après le
mexique la pologne est quand même un
pays de taille moyenne
je pense que si la pologne est poussé
vers la sortie de l'union européenne
c'est toute l'union européenne qu'il
remise en question fondamentalement
après le choc anglais britannique a
fortiori alors vous l'avez évoqué
parallèlement à cette décision attendue
de la cour constitutionnelle polonaise
la cour de justice de lieux a condamné
la pologne sur demande de la république
tchèque condamné à payer 500 mille euros
par jour tant que la gigantesque mine de
charbon de tours au reste active c'est
une sanction inédite au niveau européen
c'est une jolie édité évidemment c'est
toute la question de la politique
énergétique de l'union européenne
qui est remise en cause par la pologne
et par l'union européenne vis-à-vis de
la pologne à la demande évidemment de la
république tchèque mais la république 5
se fait l'interprète évidemment d'une
logique européenne qui va à l'encontre
des choix économiques que font un pays
ou un autre et en l'occurrence pour la
pologne le charbon est considérée je
dirais comme un mix national fondateur
et puis un moyen d'assurer
l'indépendance énergétique de la pologne
ce qui repose la question que j'ai
mentionné tout à l'heure est ce que la
souveraineté nationale est prioritaire
dans le cadre de l'union européenne ou
au contraire la souveraineté européenne
si on peut parler si on peut utiliser
cette expression tout dernier mot est ce
que la pression de la part de bruxelles
qui vise à couper la manne financière
est ce qu'elle est efficace sur varsovie
on verra justement c'est un bras de fer
toute la question est de savoir si la
pologne va être toute seule si la
pologne et toute seule elle aura
évidemment de la difficulté à s'affirmer
en revanche on sait que l'union
européenne est dans une phase difficile
et c'est peut-être pas par hasard que
varsovie a choisi ce moment là pour
essayer de profiter de cet
affaiblissement de cette crise
intérieure pour essayer de trouver des
alliés de choix dans les états qui comme
la hongrie mène une politique assez
comparable à celle de varsovie ce soit
dans des forces politiques que l'on
retrouve dans différents pays et qui
compte même si elles ne sont pas
officiellement au pouvoir merci beaucoup
pour votre éclairage d'une audrey free
historien spécialiste de l'europe de
l'est